- So Jim, you're still doing
standup during these times,
so how are you making that happen
and is it better or worse?
- Well,
you know, I've become so dependent
on a certain endorphin rush.
I don't know how often
you consistently perform.
Obviously this show is a
creative outlet, obviously,
but I did standup 300
nights a year for 30 years,
and then for four months I didn't.
So there was something about,
I was craving the
performance, but it's weird.
So I do these drive-in shows,
where I essentially do
everyone's safe, social distance,
a parking car away from each other,
but you're performing for cars.
So it's a little bit like
being in that movie, Cars.
Like, I feel like I'm Mater.
Like, I'm on stage
and I'm the car performing and it's weird
because the feedback, rather
than applause or laughter
is flashing lights.
So people will flash their lights.
Occasionally they'll beep.
They'll be like beep-beep,
kind of like get out of
the way beep is good joke.
It's weird.
It's a different type of language.
- Oh that's such a cool
and clever idea, though,
just to get people one,
out of their house,
but their safe and all of that.
It's a really great idea,
and I love a drive-in movie theater.
- [Jim] Yeah!
- I think they're so
awesome and personal and fun
and kind of a whole experience.